a video yes I've never seen two whole
goats in a biryani before
first I'm tenderizing them with vinegar
then they'll be stuffed with chickens
quails and eggs and served on a bed of
fragrance
okay Brinson now we're coating the goats
in ginger and chili you just five five I
just like that
Imtiaz makes it clear that great indian
cookery is instinctive there's no recipe
as such you know whatever the new
student comes and you try to learn so
you should respect the the teacher you
know I definitely respect the changes
trust me it looks like I'm a guy I don't
want to fall out with okay in terms of
technique this dish is as complex as
anything in Michelin star cookery I'm
now marinating the chicken and the
quails in the chili ginger garlic and
yogurt mix what is a basic take away in
Britain is a finely tuned feasting dish
in India
No yeah I think it's 450 okay but I
would looked at the chance to work for
him yeah when he was a Rottweiler then
I'm the age of 35 yeah well look at the
hands I like shovels look oh my god
amazing amazing amazing making for
stronger than odds huh this father was
old world 135 years old he's father's
135 years oh Jesus seriously I have seen
a man Matane hood your father was on in
35 he's been too much Oprah on the fire
the one thing in g oz isn't bullshitting
about is the food the hard pulled eggs
are coated in saffron egg inside the
quail I haven't had a master class like
this since my kamyshev days in Paris
that way the eggs go inside the quail
the quail inside the chicken
and finally we stuff it all in the goats
it's almost like sort of rewinding
giving birth
yeah you're putting it back in once it's
been born we're gonna stitch up well it
was a dish that was put together for by
a Lisa Josh Thole ah but this this dish
was made for only for a king but don't
let it not just make him stand or stand
up this sure beats a supermarket career
Eddie meal the goats have been left to
cook for three hours the final stage is
the rice for the Brioni first we clean
and part ball basmati rice so the rice
is towards that a bag of sort of
aromatic spices says like a bouquet
garni
now I'm learning the technique known as
dumb cooking the rice is placed in a
special pan and saffron a salad then the
pan is sealed with pastry and the right
is left to steam but one small mistake
can mean disaster
I know time to put on the pastry seal
but it's not happening quick enough for
MCS what's wrong okay no today he's
gonna let rip at me in a minute
yep
the biryani is finished with spicy
Indian meatballs called kofta coriander
and dried apricot amazing ask him for
the first time this morning is he happy
with it hello pinky hide your apnic yeah
joking equal feel it happy with it good
excellence at the beginning I felt like
a bit of a spare prick at a wedding 10
minutes into it he made me feel like a
chef thank you that's [ __ ] delicious
wine I fear is living in Britain for
last 84 years will have a completely
different take on Indian food you know
that I I swear to god it's delicious
yeah authentic and amazing
fry sliced onion with chopped chilli and
ginger crush and garlic and fry until
soft then add chilli powder turmeric
garam masala and sugar stir in the
tomato puree and chopped tomatoes blitz
fry off the chicken pieces pour in the
blended spice mixture and add curry
leaves cover and simmer stirring yogurt
and chopped coriander and serve chicken
tikka masala
done
now this is what I've travelled into the
wild for the chutney of the Derulo's hmm
Wow spicy mmm Jesus Christ it's hot hot
yeah but it is absolutely delicious I
mean really this fresh
I'm never gonna touch mango chutney for
the rest of my life but this is not a
fruit how do you make that if you like
convict me in the jungle I'll show you
what is this thing okay mmm there's a
secret get into the jungle
yeah half orange it's a bird not sure
actually some time talking over to pass
intelligence what is it inside that
chutney that makes it so bloody
delicious it seems the mystery
ingredient is at the top of this 80-foot
tree no so surprising what about a
safety rope also people he's cutting
down a branch with what looks like a
nest on it so this is the thing on
that's it yeah
oh my gosh cool so the turkeys made out
of ants and they bite everywhere jesus
christ almighty are they poisonous or
not both you [ __ ] when they bite they
bite how does that make a chutney and
and eggs so using the eggs
your accent will answer what so it's
like an ant caviar yeah absolutely
they're the eggs is that gonna come
but tasty right tell me hos test hmm
it's it's sour
yeah sour sour but our taste yeah like
Emily yeah like tamarind but it said
this little bit sweetness there as well
when you burst the eggs inside this is
why I come to India any good chef loves
fresh ingredients for such a tasty dish
the chutney is easy to make red chilli
salt and ginger are ground up with some
hands and their eggs it's rich in
protein in a place where meat is hard to
come by so use 30% eggs and 50% ants hmm
that's what you call a chutney mmm yeah
rather than that dude goodbye manga
start off by toasting your cumin it's a
dry roast basically non-stick pan so
touch of seasoning the salt helps to dry
out the humans even more and then fresh
ginger slice them nice and thinly stack
it back up and then just slice nice
little thin slices in there and then
keep that bunched up
sacred city
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot now garlic nice now
I thought of all - you're toasted cumin
seeds and in with a garlic ginger and
chili lovely it feels strange when you
talk about garlic or breakfast but the
time I spent in India everybody was
eating something savory for breakfast it
was extraordinary eats your bowl and set
aside next the pancake filling and olive
oil to a hot pan mustard seeds in now
they'll start dancing the minute they
hit the pan
then finally slice an onion onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and a good color and instant
change leftover potatoes just slice them
smell is incredible take us in now
spread the potatoes across the pan while
the potatoes stained I want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge season those
potatoes and it really helps to bring
out spice beautifully
they're ready turn off the gas and let
me sit there and absorb all those
flavors back to the pancake batter have
plain flour to your cooled garlic chili
ginger and cumin seeds touch salt and
pepper
nothing worse than the bland pancake one
whole egg milk hold the jug one hand and
whisper a secret to give an really nice
smooth paste
but whisking that egg first and brings
it together and then your milk in then
put all the milk in does anyone get a
lumpy pancake mix if you put less milk
in it really helps it not going on paper
look at that Nokia
the secret for me is to have a nice thin
mix now just a little teaspoon of oil
that helps to bring a nice crispy edge
to the mixture now taste that's the
texture panel allows of the pan the
better it helps to create a nice thin
even surface I want that mix get all the
way around the pan before you put the
mixture into the pan make sure you give
your pancake mix a really nice stir pan
it's nice and hot turn down the gas a
touch of olive oil it get that nice
whisk with one hand pan to the mix in
one and a half ladles and then roll it
around it is really nice and thin I want
to see the ginger the garlic that's what
I'm looking for in there now back onto
the heat only starts to remove from the
bottom of the pan and lifts itself up
once it's cooked these little bubbles
confirm those just aren't and lift off
the pan a little shaking that releases
it and then just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the contour
tossing then use a spatula and turn it
over now that's exactly what I want that
nice sort of crisp edge around the side
the color on the pancake is so important
now volley rounds I just let it slide
out usually
and if now the exciting part filling
them take your potatoes you just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line and
then just very carefully roll they're
nice and tightly tuck it underneath
there put it back and roll
usually the delicious pancakes are ready
to eat but with a simple dipping sauce
there'll be a real treat just mix
chopped coriander with natural yoghurt
that's really nice cooling agent sit out
on the site and that for me is a great
brunch delicious spicy pancakes
amazing
for the curry paste add chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger garlic and
kaffir lime leaf to a pestle and mortar
next put an aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander a pinch of salt black pepper
then bash it into a rough paste finally
add olive oil to loosen and your paste
is done now onto the pork neck add a
glug of olive oil to a hot pan and brown
the diced meat carefully making sure
each side hits the heat locking in that
flavour remove and in the same pan cook
sliced onions until brown around the
edges add the curry paste and fry to
release all the intense flavors then put
the pork back in along with a coconut
milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar more
kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and fish
sauce to taste then simply simmer for an
hour
slow-cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful serve with
fresh mango salsa pork make curry
slightly tilt a knife down
one at the top and then gripping the
onion like a tennis ball holding it
together in place